you know your presidency is in trouble
when you are bragging about mass firings
but unfortunately for joe biden whose
poll numbers are tanking on every
single issue the best thing he's got to
brag about these days is the huge number
of his constituents who are losing their
jobs because they are losing their jobs
in the name
of public health
these requirements work
and as the business roundtable others
told me when i announced the first
requirement that encouraged businesses
to feel they could come in and demand
the same thing of their employees
more people are getting vaccinated more
lives are being saved let's be clear
when you see headlines and reports of
mass firings and hundreds of people
losing their jobs
look at the bigger story
i've spoken with scott kirby ceo of
united airlines who's here today
united went from 59 of their employees
to 99 of their employees in less than
two months after implementing the
requirement 99
99 because they fired all the ones that
weren't in that that 99 99 lots and lots
and lots of people are going to lose
their livelihoods in order to pressure
other people to get a vaccine that may
or may not prevent them from getting a
cough
is joe biden sure that we are the ones
who are not looking at the bigger story
here i don't think so i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from old-schooled man
that you know when when my producer
sends me in these comments in the
morning i don't see whose name it is i
just see the comments once again old
schooled who he keeps coming up here on
these comments he writes one of my sons
is actually named brandon and he's on
cloud nine because he thinks the whole
country is cheering for him it's true
and every single day more and more of
the country is cheering him on let's go
brandon when you want to see things
clearly but without eye strain without
that nasty blue light that can give you
headaches and things like that i
strongly recommend you check out blue
blocks i no longer look at a screen if
i'm getting blue light from that screen
i don't i just don't do it i do it as
little as i possibly can you don't
realize how much the blue light damages
your eyes and leads to that digital eye
strain until you you get rid of it okay
symptoms of digital eye strain include
blurred vision headaches dry watery eyes
can include anxiety depression low
energy blue blocks was created to change
this with high quality lenses for
daytime nighttime and for color therapy
exactly in line with the suggested
peer-reviewed academic literature
they've got over 40 hip frames come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers
it frames for every single need blue
blocks
is also giving back by working in
partnership with restoring vision in
their buy one gift one campaign for each
pair purchased they donated a pair of
reading glasses to someone in need
go check it out today blueblox.com
knowles use the promo code knowles at
checkout to get 20 off and enjoy free
shipping on orders over 115 bucks get
your energy back sleep better block out
the unhealthy effects of blue light with
blue blocks b l u b l o x dot com slash
knowles click the link below make sure
you use code nols to get 20 off your
order enjoy free shipping on orders over
115 bucks
blublox.com slash knowles for 20 off
today
joe biden
semi-coherently and i'm being generous i
think i gave this speech yesterday about
the vaccines
and the vaccine mandates and how it's
great if a lot of people lose their jobs
because they're not vaccinated because
then that might encourage other people
to get vaccinated
and we need certain people to get
vaccinated okay it's not just about your
personal choice it's not just about your
liberty as biden had said a few weeks
ago
this is about the public health and
biden brought it home with this point
at the very least we need to get the
nurses and the health care workers
vaccinated because you if you're going
into
to your checkup if you're going in to be
treated for some other illness or for
coronavirus you need to be confident
that the people who are treating you are
not going to transmit the virus to you
we have to beat this thing
so while i didn't race
to do it right away
that's why i've had to move toward
requirements that everyone get
vaccinated or i had the authority to do
that that wasn't my first instinct
my administration is now requiring
federal workers to be vaccinated
we've also required federal contractors
to be vaccinated if you have a contract
with the federal government working for
the federal government you have to be
vaccinated
we're requiring active duty military to
be vaccinated we're making sure health
care workers are vaccinated because if
you seek care
at a healthcare facility you should have
a certainty that the people providing
that care are protected from covenant
and cannot spread it to you so you've
you've got to have that certainty that
the people at the health facility can
neither contract nor transmit the
coronavirus and that's why they've got
to get the vaccine
which does not prevent them from
contracting or transmitting coronavirus
the vaccine may reduce the risk of
hospitalization or death but this is
even according to the cdc i've got it
right here before before
youtube or whoever try to kick me off
for for spreading scientific
disinformation i've got i've got the
report right here from the cdc cdc
report shows vaccinated people can
spread covid19
so
the vaccine mandate here serves no
public health purpose the the very
argument the justification that joe
biden is giving for the covid vaccine
mandate
has no standing whatsoever it does not
carry any weight because it doesn't
achieve that purpose okay and this is
this is i think the key to thinking
about the vaccine mandates here because
there are all sorts of arguments that
people are making about the vaccine
mandates there's the arch libertarian
argument this violates my individual
liberty and you can't inject me with
anything in my body my choice then there
are
other arguments you're hearing them from
the left which is that look you
absolutely we have to protect people's
public health and you have no right to
spread germs here we all live in a
society and you've got conservatives
trying to make more prudential arguments
in the middle i think what we have to do
is look
at the specifics of this vaccine and
this virus vaccines can do two things
they can protect you
from a virus and they can protect other
people from a virus and some vaccines do
both of those things
these vaccines do not
by the cdc's own admission
so this vaccine
apparently is very good at protecting
you
from going to the hospital or dying from
the coronavirus
but it does not protect you from
transmitting the virus that's why the
cdc gave guidance at the end of july
saying that you've got to still wear the
mask even if you are vaccinated that was
the argument they made now you might say
that's that's a stupid piece of guidance
as well but neither here nor there the
justification for that is that this
vaccine does not protect other people
from the risk of you a vaccinated person
transmitting it to them
which means
that there might be a public health
there might be a personal health benefit
to having people get the vaccine but
there is no additional public health
benefit right i i understand the
argument for vaccine mandates going back
to 1905 there was a supreme court case
about this going back even further
george washington inoculated the
continental army against smallpox
the reason being that we all live
together and
other people might be at risk by your
personal
behavior but that argument doesn't hold
here if the virus is still transmissible
by the vaccinated people
which joe biden doesn't seem to
understand or doesn't seem to care about
because he's making arguments that do
not apply in this case
doesn't matter you're seeing the vax
mandates going around
in all sorts of left-wing places
the los angeles city council voted 11-2
on wednesday
to pass a new ordinance mandating that
most patrons provide evidence of
vaccination against covid19 to enter the
indoor portion of a covered location
this is a lot of businesses restaurants
bars personal care establishments and
shopping centers
retail establishments grocery stores
pharmacies are not included in that so
the very basic things you need to get
some food you need to get some some
medicine they're not going to require
that but basically everywhere else they
will the la rule will allow customers to
submit written exemptions for religious
or medical reasons but then businesses
have to require those customers to use
outdoor facilities or to show evidence
of a recent negative covid test if no
outdoor facilities are available so the
the effect of this is going to be
segregation the filthy dirty
unvaccinated pro peasants have to stay
outside and the good compliant sheep
get to go indoors for now but the rules
are changing every single day so so who
knows
it's hard to follow these arguments
because the the authorities keep
changing them so quickly
the classic example of this is fact
she's saying don't wear masks masks do
not stop the spread of a virus and then
then immediately thereafter saying no
you actually have to wear masks sorry i
lied to you i lied to you because
i wanted to make sure there were enough
masks left over for my buddies believe
me though i was lying to you then but
believe me now so the the narrative is
changing all of the time
be very clear here when we're talking
about the vaccine mandates you don't
need to go so far as to say that
that the vaccines are evil and they're
going to inject you with microchips you
don't need to go so far as to say that
all vaccine mandates at all places at
all times are wrong it will suffice to
point out that this vaccine mandated for
this virus
has no leg to stand on it does not
achieve the purpose that its proponents
are
suggesting it will achieve
speaking of
death it's kind of a kind of a morbid
topic
california has gone further beyond just
these these vaccine mandates they have
gone further to
make assisted suicide
easier
you have a new signed a bill into law on
tuesday that will make it easier for
terminally ill patients to kill
themselves right now you terminally ill
patients can already kill themselves in
california but they have to wait 15 days
before their families can get the lethal
drugs and and kill off their relatives
now you only have to wait 48 hours uh
the law also requires healthcare
providers to post their physician
assisted suicide policies on their
websites the reasoning for this the
reasoning for making it easier for
for depressed people to kill themselves
is that
a third of the 400 terminally ill
patients who requested assisted suicide
drugs uh in in recent years
died
before they had reached that 15-day
waiting period before they'd reached the
end of it
so because of that because of the awful
cruelty
that the people who were trying to kill
themselves died before they had the
opportunity to kill themselves we need
to make it easier for people to kill
themselves
um
i see i was already having trouble
following the lodge the scientific and
medical logic of the day but that that
one is really hard to wrap your head
around
it's it's cruel that the people who are
trying to kill themselves died before
they had the chance to kill themselves
and so we need to make it easier to kill
themselves what so they don't get an
extra five days or something is that why
there's a personal twist in this as well
which is really really disturbing and in
a way it actually gives you a little bit
more sympathy for someone like gavin
newsom who's a very unsympathetic
character gavin newsom has a personal
connection to this issue here and
and i think it actually reveals uh so a
lot of the illogic
of the people who were supporting
dr assisted or just broadly assisted
suicide
what we want to do here is not support
death we want to support life which is
why you ought to check out 40 days for
life a lot of people talking about life
and death these days and specifically
they're talking about abortion with
these court cases winding their way up
to the supreme court new pro-life laws
in texas in florida
if you're struggling on what to say or
how to say it when abortion is the topic
of conversation you need to check out a
recent new book what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion since its release it has
already been a number one amazon new
release and a number two amazon
bestseller it's already on its second
printing it's an easy book to use tells
you what to say what not to say and its
proven arguments have worked with
everybody people on the fence abortion
supporters even planned parenthood
workers
this is an absolutely
invaluable and timely tool so get it now
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion how to change
minds and convert hearts in a brave new
world go to amazon or get it directly
from 40 days for life you can do that at
40daysforlife.com that is 40 days for
life dot com
gavin newsom signed into law this this
assisted suicide bill to make it easier
for depressed people and
terminally ill people who obviously are
depressed to kill themselves
gavin newsom seems to have admitted in a
magazine interview
to helping his mother kill herself
so this this is from
uh 2002 this occurred in 2002 from the
interview quote in may 2002 his mother
decided to end her life through assisted
suicide newsome recalled quote she left
me a message because i was too busy hope
you're well next wednesday will be the
last day for me hope you can make it
uh newsome's mother had had cancer
newsom
says i saved the cassette with the
message on it that's how sick i am the
interviewer writes he crossed his arms
and jammed his hands into his armpits i
have ptsd and this is bringing it all
back he said the night before we gave
her the drugs i cooked her dinner
hard-boiled eggs and she told me get out
of politics she was worried about the
stress on me this is a horrifying
horrifying scene to think about
that that newsom's mother governor of
california his mother calls him up she
was terminally ill
who knows when she would have died very
often the predictions on these things
can be way way off
and she just said you know i don't i've
got cancer i don't want to live anymore
i'm going to kill myself hey son i'm
going to kill myself i hope you can be
there
and and she
had her son come there to help her kill
herself and he said he still has ptsd
from it of course he does
it's a horrible thing for her to do and
it's a horrible situation he was put in
and it's a horrible thing in general
it's an evil evil thing in general
she died at 55 years old very very young
in san francisco 2002 this was while her
son was a member of the san francisco
board of supervisors at the time
assisted suicide suicide was a felony in
california no longer is
this is
gaining in popularity they call it
euthanasia assisted suicide
it's gaining in popularity there are
really dark
really really dark versions of this
there was a story out of the netherlands
where an old woman had been scheduled
for assisted suicide but she was sort of
out of her mind a little bit and she
would go out of her mind and come in and
she was varying degrees of lucidity and
when the time came for the scheduled
assisted suicide she she begged them to
stop she tried to smack the poison out
of their hands actually her family
members had to hold her down while the
doctor killed her while she was
struggling to survive so there are these
really ugly things people who are
depressed people who feel their burden
on their families people who feel
they're too old and they'll they they
give in to this kind of despair
it's a very very hideous sort of thing
but you're seeing it even for young
people people who are very sick
this is
an evil thing
in and of itself because
the premise here is that
suffering is the worst possible thing in
the world
the only reason to live is to feel good
and to have pleasure and the moment that
the pleasure and the feeling good wears
out or you feel that your burden to
somebody or you think life's not quite
as bright as it used to be you ought to
just end your life that is
a very perverse logic it's going to lead
to a lot of people
offing themselves and it it also is
based on a false understanding of of
our own bodies
and the left leans into this but the
right does sometimes as well especially
the libertarian right we have this idea
that we own our bodies and we can do
whatever we want with them you know do
whatever you want doesn't bother me just
don't make me pay for it but you know
you have a right to do whatever you want
with your body you own yourself no you
don't no you don't you don't own
yourself you don't have a right to do
whatever you want with your bodies i
know that this very liberal lowercase l
idea has pervaded the left and the right
these days but it's just not true you
have obligations to your family to your
community to your nation and to your god
to the transcendent moral order you
don't have the right to do
a great many things
not the least of which is you don't have
the right to kill yourself okay
speaking of death and distress a really
it's a really downer kind of of a news
cycle well luckily we've got we've
actually got some good news coming up
too but before we move on to that
we do have to talk about abortion all
right this is the last last piece of
death i think we're going to be talking
about here but but there is a bright
side i think the left is
is uh stumbling over their own illogic
on abortion there's a writer julia ioff
i don't know if i'm pronouncing that
correctly
she's a
popular writer on the left and she
posted this whole tweet thread about
abortion and how terrible it is if you
are pro-life or she refers to pro-lifers
as anti-choice and she says if you are
anti-choice and you want to make sure
women carry every pregnancy to term why
not make the person who created the
pregnancy contribute why not have men
pay child support to the women they
impregnate surely it is not the women's
woman's responsibility alone
yeah sure that sounds good
yeah good idea
yeah yeah i bet you pro-lifers don't
want men to have to stick around and
take care of the mother of their child
and the child himself
uh no we would like that that would be a
good thing yeah maybe we should make it
harder to get divorced yep that sounds
awesome great idea yeah and maybe we
should discourage uh casual sex and the
hookup culture uh-huh keep going what
else do you have
yeah and maybe we should encourage a
traditional family structure uh-huh
you're on it baby let's do it julia
where can i vote for you this sounds
great sounds great so this has happened
a few other times
where these pro-abortion people think
they've got a real zinger on the
pro-lifers
because they'll
they'll say maybe you should hold the
men accountable and then all the
pro-lifers every single one of them
every single one in the entire country
will say yeah that's a good idea and
what this reveals
is that
the pro-abortion side
they come to their ignorance honestly
okay i actually mean this sort of as a
compliment
they're not i don't think generally
they're just lying
about
their motivations
i think they genuinely believe
that people who oppose abortion
pro-lifers
do so because they hate women
and they want to control women's bodies
and they want to keep women as
second-class citizens
i think that's what they genuinely
believe in fact i know that's what they
genuinely believe because when i was
young and stupid back when i was a
teenager
i thought that i was pro-abortion okay i
thought the arguments for pro-life
didn't make any sense to me i mean that
was the case until i was about i don't
know 19 20 years old
i remember i had a conversation with a
bioethicist during a summer fellowship
once
and she
disabused me of my stupid pro-abortion
notions but i really had it in my head
that pro-lifers they just you know they
just didn't respect women they didn't
think women ought to have the choice it
didn't occur to me that the baby
was was actually the subject in this
discussion not not just the woman or the
man or the society or the economy or
whatever that the baby actually had some
rights as well so i think it's good when
these stories come up when these when
these pro-abortion people come up and
they think they've got a real zinger
here i think we need to speak loudly and
say oh you're absolutely right good job
honey yep that's right let's end no
fault divorce yeah let's make sure that
men have some say over whether or not
their kids get killed and let's make
sure that men are have to bear some
responsibility for raising their kids
great stuff love that idea
speaking of
pro-life
you know that nancy pelosi pretends to
be a practicing catholic but she
is in a great disagreement with
catholic teaching on a very important
issue a non-negotiable issue that is the
right to life and so this is a grave
mortal sin and this is a
actually entails another sin which is
the sin of scandal because she is
leading people astray by pretending to
be a practicing catholic while
supporting the widespread slaughter of
babies so nancy pelosi's archbishop
archbishop salvatore cor de leone uh has
come out he's a very strong bishop very
very strong defender of the faith
and he has uh he's called for the
conversion of pelosi's heart he says a
conversion of heart of the majority of
our congressional representatives is
needed on this issue beginning with the
leader of the house speaker nancy pelosi
i am therefore inviting all catholics to
join in a massive invisible campaign of
prayer and fasting for speaker pelosi
commit to praying one rosary a week and
fasting on fridays for her conversion of
heart
it's a great idea the reason i bring
this up
you know especially for non-catholics
this might seem kind of weird the idea
that just prayer and fasting are good
ways to effect
positive change in the world but they
are this is the tried and true method
okay and just yesterday
we celebrated a very important
anniversary here in the west it's the
anniversary of the battle of lepanto
october 7th 1571 it's one of the most
important battles in all of history it
was it was a battle between the holy
league under uh saint pius v
and the the ottoman turks who were
invading the muslims have have
come close to
conquering the west on three occasions
the battle of poitiers the battle of
also known as the battle of tours in the
eighth century the battle of lepanto in
the 16th century and the battle of
vienna largest cavalry charge in history
in the 17th century and
these were massive moments when
civilization as we know it could have
disappeared
and
there have been victories that some
might call miraculous in in the case of
the battle of lopanto whose anniversary
we celebrate yesterday the the holy
league was vastly outnumbered by the
ottoman turks and
what did the christian west do
prayed the rosary prayed for the
intercession of our lady and actually
this is why there's a feast day in the
catholic church uh which is our lady of
victory our lady of victory
yesterday our lady and and so
the the
this prayer i obviously you know
the the soldiers the sailors the
fighters they did their part but there
is this idea that we actually our
prayers are
effective
our prayers can actually do things
our physical life in our metaphysical
life our physical life and our spiritual
life are actually connected and so one
simple thing we can do we can write
op-eds we can campaign we can go vote we
should do all of that you can also
prayer pray and fast you can also do
that yourself and i know you might think
it's crazy and kooky and strange but it
has served our civilization well for a
very very long
time
speaking of violence
there's a story coming out of texas a
school shooting usually the media blasts
school shootings all over
the tv and the newspapers and everywhere
this one though you may not have heard
about so much
the reason that you may not have heard
about it is that it contradicts the
prevailing narrative on school shootings
how does it do that because in the
prevailing narrative on school shootings
all the shooters are white
uh in this case the school shooter was
black
furthermore it contradicts a lot of the
narrative on criminal justice because
what we always hear is that the cops go
really easy on white people and they're
really harsh on black people
but in this case the 18 year old student
who shot up at texas high school
was just released on bail
he shoots
four people
injures four people
shoots up the school and he gets
released
on bail
and so i don't i don't i was very sad
it's sad whenever anyone
shoots up a school or shoots up a
community or you know commits any act of
violence
but
that doesn't necessarily make it a
national news story i mean these things
do happen the reason i mention this
story
is to point out
that this sort of thing never would have
happened if the kid were white if this
if the school shooter were a white kid
he never would have been released on
bail
there would be marches there would be
wall-to-wall news coverage
and
and there isn't now because it
contradicts that narrative and i i don't
want to fall into the trap of saying you
know if the shore on the other foot or
you know if the roles were reversed it
doesn't matter if the rules were
reversed there were double standards in
this country but you got to point it out
when it happens you have to be aware of
it because some people i think are still
locked in that matrix okay
one of the most persistent
myths canards
from
the the left's narrative on race in the
criminal justice system and specifically
on school shootings and church shootings
and race relations
is that dylann roof he's the guy who
shot up a black church in south carolina
dylan roof when he was arrested he was
he was taken alive he wasn't killed in
in
the act and he was taken alive and the
cops took him to burger king have you
heard this lie
the cops first of all the cops didn't
take
an arrested
mass shooter to burger king okay nobody
could you imagine the cashier at burger
king if the cops walk in with this
deranged killer no obviously that didn't
happen the cops arrested him but they
did bring him burger king
okay why did they bring him burger king
because they had to feed him it is the
law that no matter how heinous a crime a
person commits you have to protect
certain basic rights including their
right not to be starved they have to be
fed
furthermore the reason the cops bought
dylann roof burger king is because if
they didn't if they didn't get them food
if they didn't
uh satisfy these basic requirements of
the law
he might have been able to get off the
hook
or at least it would have raised
problems for the trial because he and
his lawyers could have claimed that his
rights were violated and it would have
complicated the trial and would have
made it harder to punish him buying
burger king for that shooter for dylan
roof
made it easier to punish him it was a
tool and an instrument in order to
bring justice to that shooter okay
in this case you're not going to hear
anything about that
he was led off the hook he was released
on bail you're not going to hear
anything about that because it doesn't
fit the the racial narrative
remember this story remember this story
the next time the left brings it up
the next time the left tries to
construct one of these kooky
kooky racial narratives about it okay
it's just
not
true
oh you saw it with the whistle the quote
unquote whistleblower this week at
facebook
the
the valiant whistleblower who
is speaking truth to power and that's
why she's being lauded by every powerful
institution in the country
virtually every single one right no
she's not a real whistleblower she's not
really speaking truth to power
the the the
narrative over who is oppressed and who
is doing the oppression
when it is being pushed by the ruling
class is almost almost always exactly
the reverse
speaking of double standards
rashida talib who is i guess she's the
the george harrison of the squad aoc is
paul
ilhan omar is john
uh ayanna presley is ringo i think i
think rashida talib is the george
harrison of the squad she is a radical
leftist member of congress
she was just caught on camera admitting
that the only reason she ever wears her
mask is in case hostile media are
filming
greg has been out in all of our uh all
of our community
it's a little hard to hear on this video
the video as she says at the end is
being filmed by a republican tracker so
for congressional campaigns the opposing
campaign will send some punk kid with a
cell phone to to film you all the time
and try to catch you doing something
unfortunate as as actually happened to
her she did it to leave in this clip
but she's got the mask and she's talking
about the mask and then some guy goes oh
yeah i'll put my mask on she goes oh no
not you no don't worry no it's not that
the only reason i've got to wear mine i
only wear it because i've got the
republican tracker following me and she
actually as she tells him that she pulls
the mask down and of course that's true
we know that all of these people
ignore the rules when they think
nobody's looking that's true of gavin
newsom that's true of nancy pelosi it's
true of elizabeth warren it's true dr
fauci it's true of all of them okay it's
true of every single one from joe biden
it's true of all of them
but we've got to keep up the fiction
right we have got to continue the
fiction
i mean i don't
except for the very narrowest of
circumstances where i have to for
instance
wear the mask at least partially if i'm
on an airplane or i won't be able to get
on the airplane and i've made a
prudential judgment that's better to go
fly somewhere than it is to sit at home
and not have the mask on other than that
i don't wear the thing because it's it's
obviously not serving a scientific or a
medical purpose it is merely a symbol of
a political power grab and i do not cut
into that sort of thing
speaking of double standards before we
go we will get to the mailbag
before we go though i have to get to
this this point the telegraph the
newspaper the telegraph was complaining
about how james bond
in the movies dates younger women and
this is terri james bond dates these
younger women and it's terrible and it's
creepy and
it would never happen the other way
around so they they
tweeted quote flip the genders and
suddenly everyone sits up in horror this
was the promise of the mother a
neglected bbc funded drama playing a
burly carpenter called darren daniel
craig was 34 at the time 32 years
younger than the film's leading lady
anne reed who was 66
and the movie didn't do well and it
turns out that people actually don't
want to watch a 34 year old guy sleep
with a 66 year old woman and can you
it's just such a double standard in the
sexism imagine if the genders were
flipped
but yeah if my aunt had cojones she'd be
my uncle right
yeah if if wishes were horses beggars
would ride what do you mean if the
genders were flipped they can't flip
because men and women are different i i
know that the transgenderists today the
the radical gender ideologues today
think that men and women are exactly the
same that includes the feminists that
includes everyone from the feminists all
the way to the transgenderists they
think men and women are exactly the same
and they're they're indistinguishable
and one can become the other but it's
just not true so yeah duh when you flip
it it's weird and people don't like it
that doesn't tell you
about the problems of society it tells
you about the problems of your ideology
you know this coming tuesday october
12th we are taking backstage to an
entirely new level instead of the usual
daily wire studio we will be streaming
our conversation live on stage at the
famous ryman auditorium right here in
nashville this will be an event and a
live stream
unlike any other we've done we are
thrilled to be able to share it with all
of you plus
we'll be making some extremely exciting
announcements which you will not want to
miss so be sure to tune in join me ben
bureau candace owns jeremy bourne matt
walsh andrew clavin and our live
audience for a backstage like never
before tuesday's live stream will begin
8 30 eastern 7 30 central head on over
to dailywire.com or the daily wire
youtube channel to catch the show we'll
be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the show my favorite
time of the week the mailbag first
question up from jackson dear michael
i'm a law student running for class
president on an anti-mask anti-coveted
restriction platform do you have any
tips on how to persuade people to my
side thanks i do and i actually i guess
i opened the show
talking about this
broad broad point
i don't think you should make the
argument
from some abstract ideology okay i don't
think you should make the argument from
some general rule that's going to hold
at all times for all illnesses and all
vaccines i think you should very
narrowly focus the message
point out that for the vast majority of
people covid does not pose a real health
risk
that the infection fatality rate
for the vast majority of people is
extremely low if you're under 65 you
have a 99 point
at least a 99.5 chance of survival and
if you're a young person as we're
talking about these these law school
students you have a 99 point something
like 99.997
chance of survival for teenagers it's
it's a 99.999
chance of survival so the the
extraordinary measures to upend all of
society don't seem to make a lot of
sense furthermore the vaccine while it
may protect you individually from
hospitalization and death does not
protect you fr or does not prevent you
in all cases from
from contracting the virus or from
transmitting the virus as the cdc admits
so the vaccine mandate there i think
fails on the scientific front uh from
the legal standpoint it's it's kind of
dubious even joe biden has admitted that
and from the political standpoint joe
biden and kamala harris both
uh during the trump administration said
they very likely wouldn't take the
vaccine because they thought it was
rushed and they didn't trust a vaccine
coming out from trump so now that
they're in power they've completely
changed their point of view but this is
a common point of view the vaccine
hesitancy as it's called on all sides of
the aisle and i think there are plenty
of good reasons to avoid the vaccine
including
your own risk profile right there was a
study that came out of uc davis that
said that that young certain young men
are at greater risk from the vaccine
than they are from the virus we know
that they had to pause the johnson
johnson vaccine because women died from
blood clots blood clotting we know that
there is risk of myocarditis
pericarditis there's risk of nerve
damage and so these might be small risks
but when you look at the broader risk
profile from the virus itself then the
the
the suggestion of a vaccine mandate uh
seems a little less palatable and so i
would make those really narrowly focused
arguments and depending on how lib your
school is you might lose but at least
you tell people what you really think
from bethany
hey michael my name is bethany i know i
know you read it it's right at the top
there
i'm a huge fan of your show and love
hearing your insights thank you very
much my question to you may seem really
weird but please hear me out and it'll
make sense is one related to one's
cousin's cousins
the reason i ask is because on one of
your shows you mentioned that you were a
cousin in law to hillary clinton
unfortunately i am also a distant cousin
in law of hillary clinton uh though her
through her marriage to bill clinton
does this mean we are very distant
cousins i think it does but i'm not
entirely sure
that would be super cool if we were
since i enjoy listening to your show and
it would make me feel better about the
unfortunate clinton connection if we
were also related to you the lord bless
you and keep you with i i think
i think that may make us cousins
but i i suspect we could still probably
get married well we can't get married
because i'm already married to someone
else but i i what i mean to say is i
don't you know i don't think there would
be worries about um
you know genetic problems something
tells me we're not that closely related
it reminds me of a great advice
i i once heard which is that
knowledge
is knowing that a tomato is a fruit
but wisdom is knowing not to put it in
fruit salad so i think the knowledge
here is that yes we we very possibly are
cousins
but uh i'm sure there's some distinction
to be had between uh you know
our relation and our relation to say our
our fathers sisters children
you dig you get me there's a difference
here but nice to nice to meet you cousin
from arun dear dr koffe
do you think that prior to addressing
matters of metaphysics one should first
understand physics that is
a basic comprehension of the material
world in the classical sense of the word
i ask because i've observed that while
people on the right like yourself and
stephen crowder take great care to
research the science and statistics
before opening on the covet hoax
leftists tend to begin with moral
pronouncements about the public courtesy
of wearing a mask
and claim that those who refuse to do so
are personally killing my grandma with
their bare hands do you think the woke
journalism majors at cnn would have
greater moral clarity if they were
required to master elementary statistics
and biology before offering their
opinions
well i actually think the two are
inseparable
that is
if you focus only on the physical world
you're going to miss something and if
you focus only on the metaphysical world
you're going to miss something too
and it's ironic that the left makes all
these moral pronouncements
because the left at least out of one
side of their mouth
seems to hold this very materialist view
of the world
that's that's what the cult of science
is getting at they say that anything we
can't see and touch and put under a
microscope is just not real it's
imaginary and we should completely
ignore it at least they say that
then some other times they'll say that
our bodies have nothing to do with who
we really are and if you're a man who
thinks he's a woman you're really a
woman but the other part of the time
they're saying you know the physical
world is all that there is and the
reason the cult of science is so silly
is that
well the the idea
that the physical world is all that
there is
is not physical in and of itself
so the idea of science kind of undercuts
this this uh this
materialist view of things so i think
we've got to have both and i don't think
we should even separate them very much
either i think that we need to recognize
that the physical world
has implications about the metaphysical
world now i'll bring that down to earth
i think it means that our bodies
actually have a purpose
we can know things from our bodies about
what we should do with our bodies we can
know things about this world about what
things are for i can look at the leftist
years tumbler and i can know just from
the physical
nature of the leftist tears tumbler that
the leftist years tumbler is four
delicious leftist tears right i can know
what my that my eyes are foreseeing i
can know
that there is a purpose here okay i can
know for instance from the natural world
that there is a god and i can i can
learn things about the world through
that
so yes the left needs to understand
basic physics
but but we really shouldn't separate
those two things and i think sometimes
on the right we try to do that when we
focus on you know telling people only
study stem in college don't study
anything about the humanities that's i
think that's very silly and uh and
the left obviously
makes a similar mistake but we've got to
do all of it man you got to walk and
chew gum at the same time from samantha
michael do you think people are born gay
i've had this debate with my boyfriend
of several years and he does not believe
that this is the case he feels that men
are drawn to other men because of early
sexual experiences in their lives and i
feel just like how some guys are more
attracted to a redhead over brunettes or
certain lady parts over other lady parts
gay men could also just be more drawn to
men over women i love your show and i
can't wait to read speechless
well my really sophisticated answer to
this question is
i don't know
right i
i know some of my friends
some of my friends are really insistent
that there is no
natural inclination toward homosexuality
and i just don't i don't really buy that
homosexuality is
a
persistent phenomenon everywhere in the
world throughout all of human history
and uh i i always speak from my own
personal experience
not on homosexuality but on sexuality in
general you know since i was a very very
young boy i guess in my earliest
memories i have had an attraction to
women i'd be watching tv i'd be watching
munster's reruns and i'd have i was
attracted to the blonde girl and the
three four years old i don't know
why i didn't know what that meant it's
not as though i were sexually aware or
conscious but i knew i had an attraction
to the the girl
so i
i can't help but imagine that
gay guys might have a natural
inclination toward guys i mean this is a
this is a very strange and varied world
here and people you know have kind of
unusual things about them and so i don't
think that implies that we therefore
need to
i don't know redefine marriage or you
know encourage all sorts of attractions
and say that if you know if it's natural
do it or whatever if it feels good to do
it or anything like that i mean you can
have any
sort of discussion you want on sexual
ethics
but but i don't think that relies on
on there not being a natural inclination
toward
homosexuality i just i don't i think
it's sort of beside the point if you're
gonna have a discussion on sexual ethics
i think it ought to presume that it's a
fallen world and they're got lots of
unusual things about this world and uh
and move on from there
from shane
mr knowles i find myself in a bit of a
dilemma i've attempted a great many
times through the years to attend church
in a variety of denominations i always
found the same
problem i've always felt judged and
demeaned by the people in it and most of
the people acted as though it was just
for bragging rights it was as if they
went just to flat the fact that they
went as opposed to wanting a spiritual
connection to god and their fellow man
any advice for a lost soul seeking a
deeper connection to the divine thank
you from tennessee i do
i have an answer and you might expect
this coming from me but hear me out
you should find
not just a mass you should find a latin
mass you should go find a traditional
latin mass and you might not have latin
and you don't worry you have a little
booklet you can follow along it'll give
you the english translation
but the reason you should find a
traditional latin mass
is well there are many reasons but the
reason in your case is because the
traditional latin mass is not about you
and it's not about the person sitting
next to you in the pews and it's not
about the people at all actually the
priest is not even facing the people the
priest is facing the altar and we're
actually all facing the altar and it is
all about the sacrifice that is taking
place on the altar and it is all about
god
and i i think that
that
focus is going to resolve a lot of the
problems that you're having in whatever
churches you've been going to
where it's people making it about them
and which pew they're sitting in and how
upright they are and how they look and
everyone's kind of looking at the people
and thinking about themselves but in the
traditional latin mass
you you really lose yourself
it the the smells and the bells and the
ritual and the liturgy is all it's
taking you completely out of yourself
even the fact that it's in a language
that you might not be fluent in or
familiar with and you're following along
in the english that that will take you
out of yourself and i think that's
that is the stumbling block that you're
describing right now and the best way
that i know to figure out how to how to
get out of that problem is the
traditional latin mass from lucas hey
michael i'm a new jersey resident and as
you may know
our governor's seat is up for grabs this
november the republican candidate former
assemblyman jack chatarelli
just had his first debate against
incumbent phil murphy or as my boss
calls him horse face that's not very
nice
however as a true conservative who cares
about cultural issues i wasn't in love
with some of his answers the other night
he's pro-abortion he says systemic
racism exists
i think these stances are tactical
because in a deep blue state like jersey
he has to appear moderate even to have a
chance of being elected do you think
republican candidates and blue states
should do what it takes to appear
electable even if it means giving ground
to the left or take a hard stance
against the cultural degradation that is
plaguing our country thanks for all that
you do
i think that
the buckley rule holds i think you
should vote for the most right viable
candidate
and i think there can be an argument
abortion kind of complicates this but
i think there can be an argument
for voting for squishy candidates if
there is no better option available and
if the leftist candidate poses a real
threat
i don't think there is an argument for
real conservatives lying to the people
when they run for office and pretending
to hold certain views to get elected so
they won't hold those views afterwards i
don't i think that's a bad thing and it
speaks to a lack of integrity
uh and so i i would be skeptical about
voting for someone like that but if
you're in jersey you've got to live in
reality you know politics politics at
its best has a tight connection to
reality and so i would i would recommend
that you uh
you know you you make a prudential
calculation there but it that
there's more or less of an argument for
voting for that person if you think he's
just being disingenuous and lacking
integrity
last question from jennifer michael i am
a fellow devout catholic i prefer the
term practicing catholic because i'm
going to keep on practicing until i get
it right
but good that's great great to hear from
a fellow papist uh i'm in a serious
relationship with a guy who was raised
protestant but left the christian faith
as a young adult we've known how
differently we view faith for the entire
year we've been together but recently he
started asking me what if questions
about future children he seemed fixated
on what if your son's gay and all i can
do is tell him what the church teaches
about celibacy
what would you do if you had a child
that's a very gay male bag today what
would you do if you had a child come out
as gay obviously i'd imagine you'd still
love them and encourage them in catholic
teachings but would you attend their
non-catholic wedding if they had one
would you have
relationships with their adopt adopted
children if they chose to have any i
guess what i'm wondering is where's the
line between not condoning certain
actions and still being there for people
you love thanks for being such a
spectacular role model for the faithful
thank you very much uh yes my little my
little baby is the absolute apple of my
eye and so yes i would love my child you
know unconditionally of course um i i
don't i i don't think i would be able to
change my opinion on the definition of
marriage and my faith would not permit
me to attend uh
a a non-i don't i don't even know if i'd
be allowed to attend if he had a
non-catholic wedding actually it's a
matter of the catholic faith so i hope
that i would raise him in such a way
that he would have a great reverence for
that thing regardless of his sexual
desires or any of the other issues that
can come up along the way um so yeah i
wouldn't i wouldn't like abandon my
faith and radically change my my view of
reality but i would love my son
unconditionally of course as i love my
gay friends and you know all sorts of
things like that believe it or not you
can do both this reminds me of this
question of uh
you know the the
julia ioff who said you know you
pro-lifers now how what if we made the
men take care of their kids and you say
yeah yep that sounds like a good idea
you can do you can be against killing
babies and four men taking
responsibility actually it makes perfect
sense to do all of that you can do that
despite
how viciously the the left-wing media
wants to portray us all right that's our
show i'm michael nolan's the michael
knoll show see you monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin